a wisecrack disembody Jarrett here I'm
here today to talk to you about an issue
of grave importance a dark stain on our
generation the emoji movie now you
probably all know most of the reasons to
hate the emoji movie it served as a
family-friendly vessel to cram as many
shameless product placements as 90
minutes can fit it's also predictable
painfully unfunny and tries to convey a
moral message as gracefully as this but
there's another reason you should hate
the emoji movie its politics and that's
because while it tries to tell a story
about inclusivity it's so poorly
thought-out that it manages not only to
fail at being inclusive but accomplishes
the exact opposite presenting us with a
hopeless totalitarian nightmare
seriously
welcome this wisecrack addition on the
emoji movie what went wrong and just in
case anyone gives us spoilers ahead but
first a recap the emoji movie takes
place in techstop Allah say city of
sentient emojis inside some kid named
Alex's phone gene a met emoji decides to
stop mooching off his parents and get a
job in voting for his human Overlord
problem is he has trouble maintaining
his madness expressing a range of
emotions instead but since being mad is
his function he [ __ ] his job up gets
labelled a malfunction if your
expressions other than Mac like you are
is a malfunction and evades deletion
from the text ah police fuzz as the
movie drags on his antics threatened to
kill him and everyone he loves once Alex
tires of issue I'd like to make an
appointment it's like this phone he's
playing games with me his escape is
assisted by a princess turned hacker and
a high five who loves to dance
Alex decides to wipe his broken phone
and as Jean witnesses the deaths of all
his friends which is definitely his
fault he manages to malfunction with
confidence and grace allowing Alex to
properly Mack on some girl in the end
Alex is happy with his broken phone
because it's made him a Mac Daddy and
Jean gets to express himself however he
pleases the end the emoji movie is
certainly trying to espouse a noble mess
now we are not bound by tradition or
birth and can become whatever we want
it's not a new trope the nobles overcome
their birth name for her bidden love a
warrior who wants to fight in spite of
societal expectations or pretty much any
story where someone packs their bags to
escape their small-town existence or the
big-city lifestyle it's an easy enough
concept one you'd have to try really
really hard to botch and with that the
movie botched literally every single
opportunity to sell that message so much
so it's worth discussing before we get
into the totalitarian stuff first
there's jailbreak a princess emoji by
birth but she'd rather do cool hacker
stuff like wearing beanies and watching
mr. robot instead of doing princess
stuff throughout the film she assists
Jean in escaping to the cloud and
evading deletion she eventually saves
the day by throwing away the hacker
costume reverting to a princess and
whistling for the Twitter bird in other
words you can grow up to be anything you
want but when push comes to shove you're
gonna have to sacrifice who you are in
order to become what society always
expected of you it kind of be like the
plot of Mulan
but if Mulan saved the day by going home
and cooking her father a nice dinner
before folding his laundry
then there's Jean who was born a man
emoji but is capable of laughing and
screaming and having sweet glasses
he faces discrimination by not falling
in line with the identity society has
put out for him but a conversation
between jeans parents reveals that his
father has the same malfunction
suggesting that jeans malfunction is
genetic get it Jean hmm
regardless of whether or not emojis have
DNA the idea that genes whole identity
is inherited further undercuts the
message that society and birth shouldn't
dictate what we aspire to be and because
bad decisions apparently come in threes
to further cement the message that we
all contain some innate inescapable
nature by birth
the hi-5 emoji reminds us why he has to
press buttons and eventually saves the
day by performing the task he was born
to do now that's not to say the movie
can't be trying to teach people to have
confidence in the things they can't
change about themselves but it also
manages to more or less demonstrate that
you can achieve greatness if your
genetics allow it also manages to turn
internet trolls who in real life are
horrible people by their own volition
into an identity that one is born into
and therefore cannot choose just got
dumber internet trolls just ignore them
so instead we get the equivalent of a
racial underclass subject to constant
integration so much for inclusion but
even if we wanted to concede that the
emoji movie really was about being
comfortable in your identity there's
another scarier problem it offers us a
vision of the future that to paraphrase
George Orwell's 1984 is pretty much a
boot stamping on an emoji face forever
on one level the emoji movie shows us an
authoritarian nightmare in its emphatic
furor smiler emojis are put into the
service of the messaging app and
anything that interferes with the
functioning of that app must be
eliminated
while jeans supposedly overthrows this
order by flaunting his god-given talents
what can we infer really happen to
techstop Aliss afterwards to figure that
out we need a little help from German
philosopher max Horkheimer Horkheimer
wrote extensively about an idea called
instrumental rationality or instrumental
reason and believed it played a crucial
role in the domination of humanity
throughout the 20th century especially
in totalitarian regime
instrumental rationality is the kind of
reason we use to achieve a particular
end if I've decided the wisecrack team
needs to eat 50 pounds of pizza
instrumental reason can help me figure
out the best most efficient way for them
to fill their bodies with regret drink
lots of water the day before go for the
toppings with high water content smoke
lots of ganja but instrumental
rationality is dangerous because it
doesn't ask bigger questions like why am
I trying to destroy my body or why in
god's name did I just spend $300 on
Pizza and while Horkheimer wasn't
talking about pizza or other everyday
uses a practical reason he noted that
modern society was fuelled by this
flawed kind of rationality always
figuring out the fastest way to get
somewhere never trying to figure out if
it was even worth it at all
heck Sapa list seems to be run on this
kind of instrumental rationality the
whole society is organized for one
purpose to deliver Alex the emojis he
selects here each of us does one thing
and we have to nail it every time there
are never questions like why does Alex
get to pick the emoji or hey isn't this
technically slavery and there's good
reason if they go on strike Alex will
probably uninstall the app and murder
them all see this is the problem with
anthropomorphizing utilities in films
where there are humans present it's cute
at first but when you think about it it
gets pretty horrifying
the problem with instrumental
rationality for Horkheimer is that it
aids in the domination of humanity since
it's concerned with questions like
efficiency and usefulness both nature
and humanity become inputs in the
assembly line of society as we reduce
our inner nature to instrumental
functions we lose any strong sense of
self and thus lack the inner substance
in a manner that makes us metaphorically
into nobodies and what everyone is
reduced to a use-value things get even
scarier it's for this reason that
Horkheimer and his fellow frankfurt
school thinkers characterized the
totalitarianism of the 1930s as the
ultimate danger of the instrumental
rationality that pervades our modern
world we see the totalitarian danger of
this everywhere in the emoji movie
society is organized based on how
individual emojis can be
instrumentalized in the surface of alex
emojis are used often get to go to the
cool
parties and are popular with peers while
those unused gets sent to the loser
lounge and those that disturb the peace
as with Jean get liquidated and while
the existential threat of getting
deleted based sound like good
rationalization for killing Jean it's
also worth noting that most
authoritarian regimes sell their message
through existential threats you know the
whole it's either this or the demise of
the German people stick so was jeans
victory in the climax of the film a blow
against the authoritarian terror of
smiler well no yes Jean is a revered
hero high-five is popular again and the
exclusive VIP parties of the old regime
are now open to all from now on everyone
is welcome this
it's the Eugene
however in the after credit scene we see
smuggler relegated to the loser lounge
confirming a still existing hierarchy
between usable and unusable emojis
but for Horkheimer this shouldn't be
much of a surprise as he writes what is
usually indicated as a goal the
happiness of the individual health
wealth gains its significance
exclusively from its functional
potentiality in other words the
happiness of everyone in text APPA lists
is only significant in that Alex's
texting app still works nothing is
solved in regards to the extreme
instrumental rationality of texts apples
emojis are still instrumentalized for
Alex and if jeans malfunction is now
popular it's only by the whims of their
human Overlord
we even get an emoji dance where emojis
are seemingly free to emot-- as they
please
but this expressiveness is only
permissible insofar as it doesn't
threaten Alex's social prowess and
because the film hints that genes
malfunction is inherited the implication
is a new dystopia where those with a
quasi genetic mutation can better serve
Alex while those born of lesser genes
can still be discarded so while we may
have thought that the end of smilers
regime would have meant liberation of
emotions and text APPA lists the fact
that alex is still the ultimate judge of
functionality means nothing has changed
basically the emoji still live under the
iron fist of Alex because nothing has
been done to undermine their
instrumentalization what will become of
gene when alex tires of his ultimately
meaningless emotive one day he may
decide to do away with whatever money
eyes / kissing face / sunglasses emoji
means and go straight for the eggplant
emoji as if to foreshadow this high-five
tells us early in the film what you need
are fans they give you complete and
unrelenting supports as long as you're
on top and here's the issue with making
emojis which are things with an actual
function a metaphor for humans who are
more than a utility on a smartphone
happening it makes a lot more sense to
delete an emoji for not doing its job
than murdering a human for not doing its
job int X APPA lists if the system truly
goes too far alex can just get another
phone that's not exactly how human
civilization works and here we can see
the shift in how domination has
whereas a hundred years ago the system
enforced its rules with depression like
smilers our modern society strengthened
their rule with liberation or at least
liberation within bounds as fellow
frankfurt schooler Herbert Marcuse I
wrote many of the freedoms afforded to
Western civilization only serve to make
the repression of those societies more
efficient we're given the freedom of how
to exist within the system but never the
freedom to escape the system the post
almost apocalypse world of techstop
Allah certainly seems more permissive
but what has been omitted from the story
is the possibility of escape jailbreak
once resisted the system by escaping it
living outside the app but now she's
back in techstop alice in full princess
attire the cloud then represents the
ultimate resistance to the system which
has been brushed aside by the film and
genes rho x have only served to
perpetuate this cruel system is the
ultimate message of the emoji movie
resistance is futile we're either
subjugated by a strict totalitarian
regime or we get to express ourselves
freely so long as it serves the same
master in either case freedom is an
illusion and your inescapably a pawn in
the system geez
you all and thanks for watching peace
yes well we have business to attend to
what kind of business monkey business
thanks for watching wisecrack if you
need to cleanse your palate after all
that emoji bashing and want to celebrate
what's good about movies you should
check out our friends over at cinema
wins they focus on the great stuff about
movies and they've already analyzed all
your favorite animated films including
mallanna
wreck-it Ralph and big hero 6 take a
second to check them out including their
newest video on trolls and be sure to
subscribe while you're over there and if
you can't get enough emoji movie which
is something I thought I'd never say
join Alec and I ranting a little more
about this trainwreck
on the newest episode of our patron
exclusive podcast wisecrack edition
extra become a patron and you can listen
to the podcast and check out a bunch
more exclusive content we've got a
growing library of patron only content
with a lot more on the way like early
access to videos podcast quick takes and
more so check out our patreon page by
clicking here and don't forget to check
out cinema winds here and all those
links will be in the description too and
catch y'all next time
[Music]